when you were a kid right did you think
that people were stupid
like you think that you're like too
smart in what context just in general
like as a kid i was one of those little
kids that just thought like in school i
think half the reason why i was angry
half the time right so i thought like
this is so dumb i'm smarter than all
this
right i can't even remember i just
wanted to play video games i didn't
really
i didn't feel that strongly about things
and so i i i was like i thought as a kid
i just thought i was smarter than people
around me right yeah right i think
everyone had that phase though right
right but i think people don't grow out
some people don't grow some people don't
grow out of it obviously yeah because
it's really interesting because i was
just scrolling on reddit yeah god forbid
and i i saw this and it was like a post
where i was like i think everyone else
is dumb and it's infuriating having to
talk to people right yeah and then it
was really interesting seeing how people
were trying to reply to this and kind of
like break it down and ultimately and i
i think this is really good and i think
that everyone should keep this in mind
because i feel that
we judge people based on how they speak
not how their level of intelligence is
yeah right and i feel like this
definitely happens on the podcast i've
seen in the comment section where we
might have a bad take we might badly
explain something yeah and everyone's
like well connor's dumb or joey's dumb
you can't stand you couldn't explain
this like
it's it's so hard to grasp
we only can interact with people based
on the things they say right not how
they think because you're probably
thinking about things way deeper than
you could ever explain oh yeah about it
right and it's so hard to get that out
of your head when someone's talking to
you because you have to you only have
that to work i mean it's a skill and
that's why like i have trouble properly
expressing myself unless it's written
down yeah which is why i screamed right
right which we can't do on the podcast
you can't join the podcast unfortunately
but like uh we can't like edit it either
so like that's why like i i know for a
fact that i express myself best in like
text form or like written form but also
i think you're you're quite like
eloquent with the way you word things
and i think i think i mean i've had some
pretty [ __ ] me too
just just because i was like
there has been several points where i
look at myself arguing an argument and
i'm just like i'm a [ __ ] clown why
why i deserve to be [ __ ]
true bro
trash takes comments it's been like it's
a normal thing where they'll be like i
get what connor's saying but he
explained it badly yeah yeah
and i will admit i'm extremely guilty of
that i i do that a lot and there are a
lot of things that i try to explain but
in the moment it's just hard to get the
words because we don't come into this
it's not a debate we don't script this
[ __ ] we just turn it off it's like i get
what you mean but you probably should
have double checked this like the whole
uh the [ __ ] the food illness thing
yeah if you give me 20 minutes in a room
alone right now i could probably prepare
a decent argument yeah yeah however i
don't yeah yeah but if you gave me time
to put it in an essay well i'm sure i
could tell you this is how real life is
and it's weird because i feel like when
i watch people as well speak and again
this is this is going back to how
just general life again this ties into
the previous topics with the online
right how we respond to people who have
or might be uh have bad opinions on
things
we observe to be bad opinions it's like
it's so hard
in this current climate online to just
give people the benefit of the doubt and
just be like i think you mean well and i
don't think like this this opinion you
have that could be hurting people i
don't think you genuinely want to hurt
people yeah it could be like you just
have a bat you just you have been
misinformed and you believe it yeah you
genuinely think this is helping people
that's that's the problem though is that
like i feel you know a lot of social
media like twitter reddit stuff like
that is like 99 emotionally driven yeah
right because of just humanity yeah
but also you know a lot a lot of people
like to think that like oh i see this
massive post on you know massive comment
replying to a certain [ __ ] take on
reddit right and they think like oh
judging from the length of this whole
thing this must be a very well thought
well written argument 90 at the time no
it's it's emotionally just it's
emotional drivel but that's
unfortunately how the nature of a lot of
these internet arguments yeah work right
it's so depressing you just like even
when you go on the reddit i'm like look
at it and it's just someone will say
something that's a bit incorrect and
it'll just immediately turn into like
argument yeah yeah it's like i was like
why do you want to do this don't you
it's like no one's [ __ ] citing their
sources in these kinds of comment
sections it's all it's all emotional
yeah i mean like that's i mean that's
just how humans are like always and yeah
that's why like that's why i don't
normally try to get involved on like a
platform like twitter because like i
do you think anyone's ever changed their
[ __ ] mind from like a single tweet or
like
or like a twitter discussion i don't i
can't see it happening i'd love to meet
someone who's like you know i thought
about this thing but then i saw you know
uh xxx noob killer xx tweet that i'd be
like yeah you know what you're right bro
opinion changed yeah just like that yeah
i've seen i've seen threads that maybe
you know well you know we'll just agree
to disagree you know threats that you
you open up that like show all replies
and you just keep scrolling down and it
just never ends
i see people civilized on the internet
and always being really respectful each
other is when they're talking about porn
yeah that's the only time yes people do
people are so [ __ ] polite to each
other when they're talking about poor
and they're so helpful and everyone's so
helpful about it but the moment it's
anything else it's like it they just
start going at the throats it's the
image of like all the board members
i think that's very good example right
now
yeah it's like it's literally yeah very
civilized yeah i just love as well the
ones are like you know going back to the
whole like agreeing to disagree thing
like i've seen so many twitter replies
of like how one side of the the argument
tries to you know start that whole
conclusion up being like you know what
let's agree to disagree but ninety
percent of the time the other party's
like no no no no no yeah we're not
ending it here i'm not gonna agree to
disagree [ __ ] you how dare you you you
know this that people feel for some
reason feel safe discussing their
opinions about uh port and hentai and
whatever because on some of these
discord servers where they talk about
hentai people use their real [ __ ]
pictures as their profile pictures
that's how safe they feel talk what the
[ __ ] that's the that's the real safe
space that is the real space safe space
man what it's like
instead it's bold it's like i mean
i'm into ntr let's agree to do something
it's like stephen with his actual
profile player it's like what what
why is it that like the porn community
on twitter is like some of the like
chillest people the porn community in
any community
the chillers people isn't it [ __ ] up
that like a pornhub comment section is
more chill than like a youtube comment
section
i feel like because you you to have to
interact in a community you have to have
a level of self-awareness i think oh
yeah yeah so i think that's where it
comes from it's like you're just so
self-aware that you just don't give a
[ __ ] anymore and that's when you're most
zen yeah yeah well basically it's it's a
massive barrier of entry just to sign up
an account to a porn site right that's a
level that i just haven't been able to
take
i just don't want to give my my gmail
i just want to i just want to be at that
morning where i'm like i wake up in the
morning like making an appointment
this is the most trash taste segue ever
by the way can you say that that we've
gone from like very serious topics to
signing up to a porn account i don't
know
what kind of person is like i need to
just have my say in this i gotta have my
i gotta make it known what i think i
feel like there's steps because i've
never signed up for a pornhub account
yeah i have for like hentai sites right
right i have yeah because i have yeah
because sometimes you find like a like a
lit hentai you're like i want to
remember this because i'm going to
forget the name
put in the book
as a free-to-play user of the the porn
universe i will say the the he's the
most annoying thing is trying to find a
video that i did enjoy yeah because the
problem is you know after you do the
deed you just you're not interested in
it anymore so you're like i don't
[ __ ] need this anymore and then it
just like it just goes out the recesses
of your mind and like [ __ ] a week
later you're like yo what was that
[ __ ]
a-class
there is a sobering moment when you're
trying to type in the keywords to find
the thing yeah and you're like i'm
disgusting
and you're just scrolling through these
videos trying to find it you're like no
no there's something wrong with me i've
gotten to the point where i've like
anonymously gone into forums and asked
what's your profile pic i'm not telling
you
do you know what anonymous it's gotta be
cherry i want it to be yeah
no one would ever expect the joey to use
his actual profile picture on the forum
that's true but now everyone's going to
use channels
[Applause]
yeah but it's like i was yeah because i
was like i didn't know anyone at the
time right and i was in the exact same
situation where i was like i just saw
this thing but it was on incognito
so
i don't remember what it was called all
i remember is like what the girl oh
you could log in do you know the login
information do you still use this
account no not anymore
i don't even think the website exists
anymore yeah that is the one problem
with incognito mode is that it it
doesn't give you a search history yeah
or a like or like a history like the
moment the post not clarity hits and you
close that window you're like [ __ ]
why did i do that i can't i can't go
back now
oh my god so yeah i was like one time i
remember it i was like i remember what
the girl looked like and i remember like
a certain scene so i was just like hey
i'm looking for this one series um these
are the details i help appreciate it
immediately like five people came back
being like i think it's this one you
should look it up none of them were
actually yet but i got great
recommendations we've got some new
recommendations along the way that's
pretty close
signing up for what i guess it depends
hentai and stuff it's different right
yeah normal one i don't know what would
compel me to want to pay
well like what do you mean i'll like a
peso i wouldn't want to give my [ __ ]
credit card to one of these songs
dude that feels like such a you know
when you hear about these uh which one
was it was it the new york guy who was
running for mayor of new york
anthony weiner was it
something no there was somebody who got
remembered i think rowina was one with
dick pics yeah that was it there was
someone else who was like they were
running for a political position and
then it was found out they were spending
like
like five grand a month on pornography
or something and i was like i was like
that's impressive
yes to find
ways to spend five grand that is
impressive you're definitely not
watching all of it that's for sure yeah
because how could you i don't think one
person is capable of watching that much
porn how many many uh how many like how
yeah how many only fans was these like
sub two
i don't remember who it was i do
remember yeah that sounds familiar it's
like the most chad youtuber apology not
apology video yeah yeah he was never
accused of anything he just came out
he's like guys i have a porn addiction
it's rough i was like yeah well it was
like literally ruining his life right
yeah well i it's one of those things
that i can always i always [ __ ] say
it's one of those things god damn i
gotta stop saying that connor this is a
message to stop saying it's one of those
questions
it's literally my question for you
i
it's one of those
[Laughter]
that people talk about and oh sorry
people do not talk about enough yeah
yeah and
it
it's one of those things people don't
want to give credit to it or talk about
it because it's just really embarrassing
oh yeah of course don't give credit to
how
debilitating it can be to have that
if you have it man i hope you can get
help i hope you can get out of it no
shame to you man
it's because it's hard
it's because it's something that's just
like it doesn't seem like on the
forefront of things you should be
worried about
like you know you can easily it's it's
easy to be able to justify to yourself
oh yeah a gambling addiction of course
that's bad you know you're all like an
accident
or like an alcohol addiction right i'm
just kind of destroying my body i'm
destroying all my relationships around
me like a porn addiction because like
porn is so secretive anyway you don't
you don't really have anyone to talk to
it about it's not it's not an immediate
threat i think is the thing because like
you know you hear about he's like yeah
of course i watch one i'm an adult it's
everyone does it it's fine you know
everyone most people are normal living
normal lives you know while watching
and then you know you go down the rabbit
hole deep enough and you realize oh it's
actually [ __ ] like like we're just as
bad at which point do you like accept
that it is an addiction and not just
like a recreational activity that
everyone does you know what i mean like
i think like i don't know because
when are games too addicting right yeah
yeah
is it like is it is it the hours spent
consuming that medium or is it the money
spent yeah consuming that medium or
is it both i don't know is it when you
can't think of anything other than
possible because no no one wants to help
people who are addicted to porns i don't
think it's like a thing yeah because
they're like just just stop watching it
oh just something just don't just stop
jacking off just close your eyes
put your dick away it's easy
like to me like i guess i don't know
what the actual definition of addiction
is but i guess when you should start
being worried about it is when it has
like i guess like
a tangible
effect on maybe your life yeah or in
some way shape or form but like what is
like like affecting negatively yeah and
yeah that's it like a tangible negative
effect in life or an aspect of your life
but then again like when does it become
a negative effect when does it because
just become like oh yeah i just had a
week binge drinking with the boys
because we were like partying a week you
know like like at which point does it
become a negative effect i don't know i
guess that's the hard thing about it i
think it's when it's i think in my
opinion i think it's when it's like it's
consistently
for a long period of time and it's
consistently just adding on to a
negative effect i think that's when it
becomes like a problematic addiction
because like you can like as you said
like you could have like a week binge of
like drinking from morning till night
with your boys right yeah but you're
most likely not gonna be drinking for a
while after that right like that i
wouldn't count that as an addiction like
that's like a short-term like [ __ ]
that's just destroying your body yeah
that's just that's just destroying your
body and having a good time with the
boys right but like you know when it's
like a constant amount every day or you
know for a long period of time
consistently yeah and it's just getting
worse and worse and worse and worse i
think that's when it's like yeah okay
you should probably seek help kind of
thing that in my opinion i don't know
it's when you sign up to a pornhub
account it's when you you're like you
know what i need people to know how i
feel about that [ __ ] scene like that
it was so good
i need upvotes on my pornhub
that's the one thing i don't understand
i understand like i i the thing about
pornhub comments is that i understand
people asking about like say [ __ ]
call of duty's tactics or like [ __ ]
how to get past this level uh rather
than people actually yeah rather than
people actually commenting on the porn
itself like to me for some reason like i
don't know why you would ever comment
on like a porno right as like because
you're either like watching it and
you're actively involved or like i've
never gotten to a point where i'm
watching this i'm just like i want to
verbalize what i think what do people
think about this yeah well like what i
think about this you know my favorites
are the ones that are just like just so
simple like so i'm so innocent being
like oh man 1823 what a hot scene i was
like
yeah
i guess so like
thank you for sharing that um
i wish i was that open i wish i was yeah
yeah maybe one day every one
you want to get to that point who knows
who knows
who knows have you seen some of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that sydney's been tweeting
you know like i need to [ __ ] calm her
down sometimes yeah yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if she had a
point porno account
at this point i think it's just twitter
she's gone beyond because she's gone
beyond man
why be anonymous when i can be known oh
god jesus